hello and welcome to divided states 11
days to go
can you believe it i can't so close at
least 46 million people
have already voted that is astonishing
and it's
a third of the 2016 turnout already
um i'm cordelia lynch i'm emily purser
brown second
and final presidential campaign
debate it was a really different vibe
wasn't it fewer interruptions
a bit more substance hallelujah but
still two old men
divided on every issue it was the big
event of the week the kind of television
event wasn't it you remember the last
one a couple of weeks ago
was ruined by constant interruptions i
can't really
believe how we got through that actually
as viewers we in the american public
just watching in horror as the two men
kind of unpicked each other
the debate in between then and now is
cancelled because donald trump got
covered and the whole thing got blown
out the water
so we arrived at last night with the
second and final debate
uh and a mute button that seemed to
change the tone of it cordy
yeah thank god for the mute hey let's
start by talking about
covid i mean that has been central to
this entire race
it was front and center again last night
on the debate stage
um and two completely different
takes on where the country is at where
it's going
and what their respective plans are for
it absolutely i think we are now
quite familiar with the arguments for
both men actually of where they stand on
kobe trump's position for a long time
has been that it's
under control and and that he's doing
the right thing biden's kind of one of
his central campaign promises really is
to do better on covid and get better
testing and just
essentially be more responsible is his
position and we heard that last night
biden working quite hard with some of
those well-prepared lines
to say that you know he he was going to
do a better job
trump conversely looking to the sort of
sunny up lands all this
optimism about a vaccine though when
pressed
he had to concede it's not definitely
weeks away he would like it to be a few
weeks away he would like it to be 11
days away so that there is a vaccine
before americans go to the polls
but one thing i thought was quite
interesting is trump didn't play all
that much on the fact that he has had
coronavirus since we last
had a debate moment and he he's actually
got this incredible experience as
somebody who has survived the disease
he didn't really use that all that much
and it hasn't
to my mind really changed his approach
to covert
yeah i think maybe his team had
suggested that he steered away
from being too much of the kind of
warrior having recovered from this and
you can too i think what was kind of
most striking and felt different this
time around in his
coronavirus response is that line i do
take
full responsibility we've never heard
that before
from him that's true and i think biden
you know has been constantly trying to
put that at his door and perhaps it's a
presidential thing to do to take
responsibility he does though i think
still strike a bit of the wrong tone by
saying it's getting better
people just need to get over it work it
into their lives it gives
biden an opportunity to come back with
the fact that this has ruined so many
people's lives
and he he used almost identical phrasing
as he did in the first debate saying for
you sitting at home when there's an
empty chair around your kitchen table
this is not the message you want to hear
and i think that there are a lot of
people in the country who have been
affected by this disease
who will that will strike a chord with
yeah i think biden was possibly most
effective
when he was kind of clapping back at
trump we can't
get over this we're still dying from it
and that is the reality but there was
a bit more humility and compassion than
we've heard from trump
so far on the issue an acknowledgement i
think
from him that he knows on coronavirus
needs to be perceived to be doing better
and
understanding the plight of the country
i think that the whole coronavirus
section which was really the first 15
minutes of the debate
you kind of felt like you knew what they
were going to say
no great surprises i think sparks flew
later on as they got to more contentious
issues and they both kind of brought out
their newer attack lines
one of which is about this issue around
hunter biden joe biden's son
and this kind of big scandal that has
been born
of some reporting in the past week yeah
let's go back
to this story because it's a bit
complicated but it continues to swirl
allegations in recent days have come
that
biden was involved with his son hunter's
foreign business dealings but biden and
his campaign
deny this ahead of the debate a business
partner of hunter biden
gave an on-camera statement claiming joe
biden
was aware of the dealings of his son
further reporting came from the wall
street journal casting doubt on any role
of joe biden in his son's ventures
specifically
in china so that was kind of where we
were at coming into the debate
we all thought trump might try and
skewer joe on this
and it it was quite a central part of
his platform
it's a bit of a difficult story really
because it is the scandal that has
plagued joe biden's candidacy really the
most of anything throughout the last
year and a half i would say
don't forget hunter biden was a key
protagonist in all of the impeachment
ukraine
shenanigans that we went through last
year and so the hunter biden issue if
you like is probably the most difficult
thing for joe biden to address
donald trump sees an opportunity here
and all of the reporting that's been out
in the last week which frankly hasn't
been
all that well stood up and is i'm not
sure
completely there it has created problems
for joe because he hasn't been able to
answer it directly and trump sees an
attack opportunity there and he used it
and i thought the fact that he almost
asked the question last night
really put biden on the spot yeah i
think he did a really good job on this
trump because
he was able to kind of cast this murky
image
of joe biden being a creature of the
swamp and someone that you
cannot trust that isn't transparent now
bryden had a pretty good retort back to
say don't talk to me about transparency
release your tax returns that's a good
reaction but you will speak to lots of
voters that are kind of worried that
asking questions lots of people coming
to us saying what is it with this hunter
biden story
so there's this swirling doubt that's
left and i think
[Music]
trump you know talking about for
instance his own family and their
dealings in the white house
totally i think that you got to exactly
when you said it's about the swamp i
think that voters in america don't
really care about donald trump's taxes
frankly that the tax return issue
does it change anyone's mind i don't
think so but they do seem to mind
about people being embroiled in scandal
and this whole joe biden's been in
washington for almost 50 years thing
does look there's appearances of of
deals being done and one of
trump's key uh benefits going into 2016
was he's not a politician
and whilst i know that he's been the
president for the last four years he
still
markets himself as not the politician
the outsider guy
and i'm about business and not about
dirty washington politics and in this
case
like joe biden and so i can see it
having some impact actually i think
people will not vote for joe biden
because they don't really
know what's going on yeah i can see it
having
some impact too but it doesn't quite
feel
uh you know of the proportions that we
saw with james comey for instance the
hillary clinton emails which all came
down the shoot at a similar sort of time
but it's probably one of trump's most
effective
strategies in these closing days to cast
out around biden's trustworthiness well
it's certainly the decision that the
republicans have taken as
the attack line in the final 11 days i
think that we will see this you know
day in day out for the next 11 days and
joe biden needs to keep on answering the
questions because when he avoids them as
he has
a lot in the campaign
it's not about your family it's not
about my family it's about your family
at home
queue look down the camera yeah
bingo prepared line um but you know
maybe that is what people watching at
home are more interested in and all of
this kind of tax money business is
actually
a bit far away yeah it's sort of when
he's best doesn't he laser focus
down the barrel of the lens for sure
another massive issue
in this debate was immigration that
loomed very large
two candidates startly divergent
uh you know opinions on where the
country is at on immigration
but they share some weaknesses
on it too right definitely i think one
thing first thing to say on immigration
is
where is the wall in this election do
you remember build that wall which was
one of the central
planks of trump's 2016 campaign no one
talks about the wall anymore because the
wall has not been built it was in every
piece we ever did yeah
so immigration is actually not one of
the issues of this cycle i would say but
it has been brought up in public
discussion this week because a
horrible horrible story about 545
children being separated
from their families who have still not
been reunited now our listeners
will recall that in 2017-18 we did a lot
around the separation
of families because of a trump policy
which was uh disincentivizing people
from coming across the border illegally
and putting children and parents in
different holding facilities now
cycle forward to 2020 now it seems that
court documents show that there's this
separation going on
families parents back in central america
children still in the united states of
america that is a
attack line for joe biden because it's
something that has demonstrably gone
wrong
under trump but trump uses it to chuck
it back to joe biden
yeah i mean that issue of celebrating
families
it kind of strikes at the heart of your
conscience doesn't it the idea that a
child would be separated
from their parents for a protracted
period but as you say
trump trying to pivot by saying look it
was you guys it was the obama
administration
that built those cages that we will all
have seen images of
that held families many years ago and
he's right
the policy is complicated because it was
happening in a way underneath the obama
administration
but the the issue the kind of the degree
of separation if you like
was more severe under trump's policy um
you know there was a lot of scandal
around it at the time
heads of agencies their heads rolled
because it went wrong
people like melania trump ivanka trump
were heavily involved in
lobbying donald trump to try and end it
there were moments in the press room you
might remember cordy where people were
appealing to sarah huckabee sanders
saying are you not a mother
do you not understand this so it was a
deeply emotional moment within trump's
first
term and i kind of thought his comment
last night about the kids being in clean
facilities
was treated well yeah it was really tone
deaf these
america has orphaned these children and
i don't think that would have sat
very well so you had those kind of more
substantive
policy debates which which was good you
know i think
we actually got to hear two very
different
outlooks for america and a bit more
detail i think
trump was quite good on the economy too
we got to hear him
and health care we got to hear him
outline uh
a few more details than we have so far
but what biden is trying to do is a kind
of more broad
brushstroke thing of saying this is
about character
ignore some of that at the heart of this
is a man that is not fit to govern
kristen welker the moderator i thought
asked a really sensitive question on
race you know she's a black woman asking
this question of two white men
she asked them what their understanding
was of the talk you know when children
of color are spoken to as kids to say
here's how you stay out of trouble
because you are disproportionately
disadvantaged just from the color of
your skin
and it prompted this sort of emotional
response from biden about institutional
racism
trump sort of took the other approach
saying what he had done for black
americans
um and it you know to to quote biden's
line
to put the character of the nation on
the ballot you know he comes back to
that again and again
but he did have an opportunity in that
moment to sort of bring that to the fore
yeah i think on that kind of symbolic
level that
told you all you need to know about the
two different men they're two different
characters but i think
trump was quite effective on the crime
build this was something
back in 1994 that joe biden was heavily
involved in which
saw black men largely
incarcerated for unduly long sentences
and he's been criticized ever since for
it he has admitted that it was wrong
that it shouldn't have happened he's
been trying to rectify
those mistakes but in the eyes of what
is often
you know a very frustrated black
electorate who feel taken for granted by
democrats
overlooked unfairly treated
i think that will have resonated
couldn't agree more and it's
completely right that donald trump's
administration has done quite a lot on
the criminal justice issue
he's brought together democrats and
republicans mostly i think under the
leadership of jared kushner
you know the likes of kim kardashian are
regular white house visitors because she
is an advocate for criminal justice
reform and they have
um pardon quite a few people and and
there is work that's been done there
whether you can extrapolate that to i'm
the best president since abraham lincoln
for black americans
which is quite a statement uh i don't
know but but
there is something you know there is
some success there for sure do you think
there was a winner
last night oh good question um kristen
welker the moderator
i thought she did a great job incredible
the audience because we actually got to
hear the two men speak
look donald trump clearly this is a tv
star right
he went back and watched the tape of
last time he must have saw how he
came across which was like an arrogant
bully and revised
how he was going to behave so the threat
of the mute button had a
huge impact on the way the conduct of
the two men
yeah and fair play to him he saw what
went wrong
and he changed his strategy joe biden
didn't really
and so he made up no ground i think
that's fair and actually it has cost him
four days on the campaign trail as well
we've been reporting this week about
you know the absence of joe biden cordy
he went and looked outside his house in
wilmington and delaware this week so i'm
surrounded by a lot of secret service
yeah i am sorry for sending you there
but that was one of many places you sent
me but don't worry i forgive you
uh but joe biden's been in in his house
for four days preparing for this debate
and maybe what we got was four days
worth of prep but
it felt like what should be baseline
performance for joe biden and trump is a
more natural performer i get that he
hadn't done really any formal
preparation sessions and the two men i
would say it was a score draw
yeah i'd say a draw maybe trump
marginally might have
had the edge but what he needed was a
knockout arguably if you look at the
polls it certainly didn't feel like that
yeah i think maybe i'm being unfair here
because our expectations of
trump's behavior are low because he
doesn't really play by the rules
him behaving like a normal politician
felt like a win for him so yeah maybe we
give it to him
joe biden the main thing 10 points ahead
in the polls he needs to do no harm and
i don't think that he did yeah i mean
i was looking at some of the kind of
history of previous debates and
for instance reagan and carter actually
reagan made up in the final debate
10 points it was you know a real bounce
and there's been other precedent for it
be surprised if trump gets that
from this i think that's right although
i think he might pick up a bit actually
yeah um
i i tell you what it brings me to the
question of do the debates even really
matter in this final stage of the
campaign you know historically speaking
in context this one is quite late in the
day with only 11 days to go until
polling day
yeah what is it going to do to the next
week and a half is it going to change
anyone's minds are there even any
undecided voters left in america
i'm beginning to doubt it yeah i'm with
you really i think it might make people
feel more comfortable or more
uncomfortable about the decision that
they'd already made in their minds
but i think increasingly these tv
debates are a dated format
that are a bit of an irrelevance when
you think of just the noise and madness
of
american politics these days the specter
of covid the economy
where you stand on race and immigration
that's more likely to kind of steer the
course right
yeah although i'm going to advocate for
the continuation of the tv debates as a
student of the jfk nixon debate i i want
them to
remain in existence because i think they
provide some infrastructure to
campaigns and it means that we all work
up towards something and you
you do kind of hear on the coal face the
two guys or two women i hope
in the future go up against each other
um they can provide
moments television moments definitely
and uh
or rather only when done well and i
think last night
was done really well well with less than
two weeks to go we put out a call to the
masses on twitter
dangerous foolish um to see if you had
any questions
um about november the 3rd that lead up
to it the aftermath so thanks so much
for throwing some questions at us we got
one here from naples
grisham they asked great name by the way
given the
ages of both candidates and health
worries
would you say this election is based on
who the best
vice president would be
look i personally think it was important
that joe biden picked
the right candidate he was under
pressure he made clear
early on that he was going to choose a
woman
and a woman of color as well he needed
to try and reassure the progressives in
the party
that he wasn't just going to be about
the same old same old
but ultimately i don't think the
vice positions of what people are voting
on this election in fact
not even sure it's really about joe
biden this is all about whether you like
donald trump
or you don't totally agree i think that
age is something that comes up quite a
lot
especially in regards to joe biden
because he has at times seemed a bit
doddery on the campaign trail and so
people are aware of the fact that we're
talking about two men in their 70s and
that's the
the vice presidential role you know
there's more of a possibility
than in past years that they would have
to step up
in the event of an emergency but i also
i completely agree that this is
really about trump and and not trump
and so uh whilst they matter i don't
think it's
having outsized importance i think what
will be intriguing if
were biden to win and suddenly kamala
harris after
a first turn gets in how the public feel
about her because they're still
very much getting to know her um you
know it's in its early stages that
relationship
the next question actually speaks to
this cordy it's from jack thompson
is it highly likely if elected that joe
biden would only serve
one term as president so kind of that's
about
the selection of kamala harris somebody
he he said on the day that he picked her
that she was ready for the job to do it
you know from whichever day was
necessary the big job i mean the pres
to be the president herself he's
indicated very forcefully that he's
doing his running
overall just to counteract donald trump
and so i think there is an
anticipation that kamila harris would
use these four years as a kind of road
up towards
her own presidential campaign again
don't forget she ran
this time and lost out to joe biden uh
so
yeah maybe he is a one-time president
yeah it feels like
i mean lots of people that would have
liked to have seen joe biden
run in 2016 there is no doubt that
there's been concern about his
energy levels his mental acuity
as well his focus and and how much he
represents the future
of the party now kamela harris isn't
exactly
a kind of fire brand of the new left of
the party
either she's pretty centrist so she'll
have her own challenges
yeah i think while we're at it actually
it's what it's who the democrats want to
be in four years time
after this hypothetical joe biden
presidency he actually said in the
debate last night
to donald trump quite a cute line i
think you've got me confused about who
i'm you know who's running i'm joe biden
i'm mr moderator i'm safe as they come
and
i'm not this kind of big crazy lefty
with all these crazy ideas that
conservatives would be scared of
you know all of which is nonsense for
what it's worth but he is a real
centrist and in four years time the
democrats may still
want to go further left than they have
been able to this cycle
and just quickly you know we should
obviously talk about mike pence because
if it's a trump victory now
mike pence is a real conservative
stalwart much more of an ideologue
than donald trump and i think he is the
kind of guy
that mitch mcconnell lindsey graham
these kinds of
senior figureheads within the republican
party would be
very happy to have uh have him at the
top i think they'd see him as sort of
stable
yes if he was put in that situation as
an emergency i think yeah if we're
talking 2024
jumping on another cycle do i think mike
pence is going to be the person that
gets
to the final you know finishing line for
the republicans
probably not because you've got ivanka
trump nikki haley the former u.n
ambassador
yep indian heritage from north carolina
an incredible
you know diverse republican candidate
when we don't often well we've
never seen anyone like that run for the
republicans
and so i think that there are lots of
exciting prospects in this post-trump
world for the republicans
in 2024 and my pens might be a bit
boring by that stage
this is a question from ian sparry
is there an alternative to these two old
blokes i'm sensing age as a theme here
cordy
good question ian uh yes what about
kanye west
what about kanye west he is he is an
available candidate in some places
available yeah um whether he is popular
well
look he officially announced his
candidacy in mid-july
he's reportedly spent 12 million dollars
on his own campaign he's only on the
ballot
in 11 states making it mathematically
impossible for him to become
the president i suppose if if ian's
question is is there an alternative to
who will become president the answer is
no it will be joe biden or donald trump
yeah
are there alternative boxes to check on
when people walk into the ballot yes
there are there's plenty of sort of
you know random other people frankly
that that you can
you could go for but the reality of it
is you need the numbers you need 270
electoral votes yeah on november 3rd
only joe biden
or donald trump will get that just on a
serious point though that third-party
candidate back in 2016 with gary johnson
and jill stein they ultimately
helped deliver trump to the white house
in those key
marginal states like wisconsin and
michigan where things were fought
over you know low figured votes you know
eleven thousand uh between clinton and
trump in michigan
they really helped elevate donald trump
this time round it's not the same
opportunity
donald trump's coming more from behind
in the polls as well
historically also there are tons of
examples the first bush of you know when
a third candidate ran and changed the
dynamic
clinton there's you know it can totally
change the race having a credible
independent candidate is just not
happening this time fascinating
questions there god there's so many
others uh some of which i'm trying to
prep for election nights like
you know disaster planning every
possible eventuality that we're looking
at i mean let let's talk about the the
week ahead em
oh gosh well there's gonna be a lot of
campaigning i think we will see
actually both candidates on the road
which will be a change for joe biden
trump's due to cast his own ballot in
person in florida on saturday morning
and so he like
millions of americans will be doing it
before election day
um i think that we're going to continue
to see evidence of this being the
turnout election if you like this
record numbers of people coming to vote
passions on both sides
um the biden campaign say on the record
that joe biden is going to be quote
unquote everywhere
in the next 10 11 days so he is going to
be i would think at multiple rallies a
day trump is already doing
three on saturday like he's at that pace
already
so our big question is do we go to the
mall i think the answer's gonna be no
you'll be like glad to hear
i'll be i'll be busy prepping yeah um no
it's been
great we've we've traveled a lot and i
think we've
taken a lot from it actually so the big
unknown for me
is when is bruce springsteen going to go
on the trail for joe biden
i'm a huge springsteen fan and i am
going to self-send
to whatever event he does this weekend
is the beginning of the celeb portion of
this uh campaign
lizzo is on the trail favorite share is
on the trail for biden
in uh nevada and in arizona i don't
think it changed minds but it adds a
little bit of spice
yeah it gives us some nice color for tv
trump's got kid rock though where will
we be in a week and a half's time
perhaps in the throes of civil war and
crisis i don't know
ah i think we may be just waiting
really as votes accounted and seeing if
the american system is
up to the job of this unprecedented
yeah do you think there was a winner
last night oh good question
um kristen welker the moderator i
thought she did a great job
incredible the audience because we
actually got to hear the two men speak
look donald trump clearly this is a tv
star right
he went back and watched the tape of
last time he must have saw how he
came across which was like an arrogant
bully and revised
how he was going to behave so the threat
of the mute button had a
huge impact on the way the conduct of
the two men
yeah and fair play to him he saw what
went wrong
and he changed his strategy joe biden
didn't really and so he made up no
ground
i think that's fair and actually it has
cost him four days on the campaign trail
as well we've been reporting this week
about
you know the absence of joe biden cordy
he went and looked outside his house in
wilmington and delaware this week so
surrounded by a lot of secret service
yeah i am sorry for sending you there
but
that was one of many places you sent me
but don't worry i forgive you
uh but joe biden's been in his house for
four days preparing for this debate and
maybe what we got was four days worth of
prep but
it felt like what should be baseline
performance for joe biden and trump is a
more natural performer i get that he
hadn't done really any formal
preparation sessions and the two men i
would say it was a score draw
yeah i'd say a draw maybe trump
marginally might have
had the edge but what he needed was a
knockout arguably if you look at the
polls it certainly didn't feel like that